il tema che voglio condividere con voi
un tema non nuovo per che parlerò di
vendite il mio tempo di ricerca quello
che mi appassiona il parlerò quello di
aspetti commerciali diremmo rispetto ad
altri devi che abbiamo sentito molto
molto tradizionale e veli racconto però
con la prospettiva di chi è molto
appassionato di chi cerca di vedere
questo mondo di chi si occupa di vendite
sotto la prospettiva più scientifica che
la prospettiva di come spesso viene
visto con molto intuito e molta pancia
il mio gruppo di ricerca mi piace
chiamarlo se il science chi si occupa di
scienza in modo della vendita per
iniziare questo ragionamento inizio da
un percorso raccontato di una mia
ispirazione e cercando di ragionare sul
concetto di stereotipo perché questo
mondo è un mondo che vive di stereotipi
e da questo punto di vista ne subisce le
conseguenze prova articolare un po il
ragionamento partendo da dove a me è
venuta l'ispirazione di occuparmi di
questi temi di ricerca che il piacere di
condividere oggi sapete l'ispirazione
nasce di solito da cose molto semplici e
non da cose troppo complesse da momenti
di quotidianità da osservazione
veramente banali direi
e allora l'ispirazione nasce un
mercoledì pomeriggio vi chiedono una
tesi su questo tema sul tema del sales
management e inizia a lavorare con il
mio studente cercando di sviluppare un
progetto di tesi che possa essere
interessante rilevante per lui ea un
certo punto di domanda
ma scusa ma tu la faresti una carriera
nel mondo commerciale
faresti una carriera nelle vendite
professori lo studente dell'alto
maceratese vi risponde professor ma chi
è studiata fa dice no perché scusate
molto diretto ma è che per fare quel
lavoro lì è necessario studiare
c'è bisogno di competenze
o non è un modo in cui o si nasce o modo
si può fare questo pensiero è fatto
molto riflettere perché vedevo un
distacco fortissimo tra quello che era
un pensiero di un mio studente è quello
che invece la realtà perché era alta un
po diversa da come la vive il mio
studente
e allora che cosa ho iniziato a
riflettere il dato riflette sulle tante
scorciatoie e mentali che ci prendiamo
la nostra vita è fatta di scorciatoie
cioè a volte per decidere e cerchiamo di
prendere delle cose già confezionate ne
troviamo di tante tipologie di tante
modalità è chiaro la realtà in complessa
abbiamo un poco tempo poche risorse
scegliamo a volte a volte non ci
riflettiamo troppo il punto di vista
dello studente era molto chiaro io ho
uno stereotipo e quello stereotipo mi
serve per decidere non affronto quella
carriera perché ho studiato questo mi fa
riflettere tantissimo perché ripeto il
mondo che vedo il mondo che vivo è
abbastanza diverso è lo stereotipo di
cui vi parlo se stereotipo delle
professioni ce ne sono tantissime
pensate a tutti gli uomini presidente in
sala che stanno immaginando la moglie a
casa con l'idraulico tutti molto
preoccupati di questo sera a casa con un
docente universitario prestiti tutti
quanti molto più tranquilli di questo
può capitare
gli stereotipi sono danni in questione
di stato si occupa di ricerca adesso non
ho portata ma se non ho grembiule che
ricerca faccio ok andiamo avanti allora
il periodico che mi interessa è la
stereotipo sul su questa figura quano la
figura del venditore a vi piace
tantissimo affrontare questo tema perché
due caratteristiche di questa
professione
ok venditori intesi in senso ampio è la
professione che che è sempre esistita o
non appena l'uomo ha inventato il
commercio e c'era qualcuno che doveva
farlo e perciò è sempre esistita se poi
vedete i dati del world economic forum
quest'anno la professione di cui
parliamo continuo ad avere un forecast
che è un fork espositivo è evidente che
sono cambiate tante cose le competenze
richieste livello di maturazione della
figura le skill che vengono richieste a
questo soggetto sono profondamente
cambiate ma il format continua ad essere
di tipo positivo l'altra caratteristica
che contraddistingue questa figura è che
gli stiamo cercando di trovare un
infinità di nomi business developer
account manager key account manager pur
di non chiamarlo venditore allora questa
è la copertina dei miei libri
ma scusate l'ho fatta ieri in aereo però
c'è la turbolenza si vede abbastanza
vale però scrive un libro abbastanza
complesso e vi assicuro è tra le cose
più difficili e faticose che che
esistono per lo meno per chi le fa ce ne
sono anche altre più complesse
sicuramente però per uno poco creativo
come me è una cosa difficilissima è
scegliere la copertina senti non vi
parlo del contenuto vuoi farlo dalla
copertina alla mi arriva l'editore che
dicevate che domani mattina devi
consegnarci la copertina
prendetene una cioè io sono interessato
a conti con una copertina personale
sceglie lei va bene la scelgo io e
l'ispirazione mi porta alla seconda a
scegliere questa copertina non so niente
di bello solo il concetto che c'è dietro
quel mondo di cui parliamo quello delle
vendite a tante prospettive diverse
da un lato la prospettiva rossa di chi
vede quel mondo come qualcosa di
negativo non positivo da pure vedremo
alcune ed altri invece che diceva no ci
serve ci serve come diventa fondamentale
se non ho una rete commerciale che
condivide i miei valori non ottengo i
miei obiettivi
due prospettive profondamente diverse
adesso andremo a vedere alcuni profili
cercando un po di studi scientifici su
questo si cui possiamo condividere
proprio questa prospettiva i media che
cosa dicono i media su questa
professione
in modo particolare di parlo di film che
lo studio bellissimo della collega
rihawi del royal institute of stoccolma
in cui analizza con un metodo semiotico
dieci film i più grandi film che hanno
visto come personaggio principale un
venditore per citare alcuni alla ricerca
alla velocità
i pirati della silicon valley lord of
war e tanti altri
quello che viene fuori però è questo il
messaggio che ci arriva dal mondo dei
media è un profilo molto chiaro con dei
caratteristiche altrettanto chiare è una
figura proiettata nel brevissimo periodo
che non si interessa della sua
reputazione
una figura che ha vive o manipolato o
cerca di manipolare vive in bilico fra
caro ten sticks bastone e carota con una
prevalenza lasciatevi dire del bastone
sulla carota ma due caratteristiche mi
hanno molto colpito di questo studio lo
stereotipo che viene fuori ha due
caratteristiche
una è una morale flessibile se tu sei un
ragioniere integerrimo però si fa il
direttore della tua morale diverso la
morale flessibile l'altra cosa che mi ha
molto colpito e che in tutti questi film
viene fuori una figura professionale del
venditore che ha problemi famigliari
adesso io non so chi di voi faccia
questo di professione in sala
però devo capire serve perché il
ragioniere c'è una famiglia del mulino
bianco e il venditore moglie che scappa
beh mi soffermo su questo però è questa
la visione dei media e se i suoi
genitori ci saranno genitori in aula
quanti di voi hanno preso in braccio il
figlio l'hanno guardato appena detto
guarda vorrei che tu fossi un venditore
allora in uno studio intervistato 2.000
duemila agenti tori 2000 genitori in
giro per l'europa
e a questi duemila i genitori è stato
chiesto che professione volevano per i
figli non vi interrogo su questo vi
svelo subito il risultato su queste 2000
solo uno coppia detto guarda io vorrei
che mio figlio fosse venditore sono
dieci anni che la cerco quando riesco a
trovarla se chiede e studenti lo
studente dell'alto maceratese già sapete
cosa pensa però in generale questo mi
piace condividerlo perché ci sono
diversi progetti che sto portando avanti
soprattutto per riflettere su quanta
questa professione possa dare una
prospettiva anche occupazionale a molti
dei nostri studenti rivedo i profili che
le imprese cercano del profilo definito
che si stanno sempre di più alzando ma
cosa pensano gli studenti
allora su questo abbiamo condotto
all'interno di in cantus che uno dei
progetti che sto portando avanti
finanziato dal dei progetti europei che
ha fortemente voluto questo progetto che
cerca proprio di dare alle università
strumenti per fare training nel mondo
sales e aveva fatto però uno studio
antecedente al progetto in cui viviamo
intervista ad in cinque differenti
all'azione di decine di studenti per
cercare di capire qual è il loro
percepito è uno dei temi per ingaggiare
gli studenti è stato quello di chiedere
quale animale fosse richiamato alla
mente nei momenti in cui pronunciato la
parola venditore vi anticipo che vengono
fuori due profili diversi che abbiamo
raggruppato un primo gruppo che è quello
più numeroso milano la risposta che in
parte scontata
il venditore è un felino una tigre
un leone o se invece non è un felino ma
è un rettile un camaleonte se è un
mammifero è una volpe ok se fosse un
pesce invece è uno non è se uno è uno
squalo uno squalo immagina la bella
reputazione che ha lo squalo dei
caratteristiche chiarissime molto chiaro
e scuola solo quello che lui vede la
preda come percepisce il salone del
venditore il business non resiste ok va
a zalla e conquista la preda
questa è una prospettiva però lo stimolo
che ci da questo studio è diverso c'è un
piccolo gruppo di ragazzi quelli che
hanno fatto un certo tipo di corsi non
solo economia in genere mai hanno fatto
corsi di sales and marketing che hanno
la prospettiva totalmente diversa perché
il percorso formativo cambia è la grande
forza di cambiare gli stereotipi per
questi ragazzi una delle frasi cittadino
degli animali citati è quello del
kangaroo il canguro ok lo coccola lo
tiene in pancia lo fa crescere e poi un
certo punto può anche lasciar libero di
andare ok ma lo cura si parla tantissimo
di customer che all'università le
università che fanno su questo la mia è
già attrezzata ma vi dico solo questo
dato
l'insegnamento sales è praticamente
assente nelle università italiane su 400
esami di marketing che ci sono a livello
complessivo solo una dozzina circa sono
focalizzati su questo tema ci fa capire
con chiarezza quello che è
l'orientamento della nostra università
c'è questo esame e le imprese alle
imprese c'erano idee abbastanza chiaro
in un recente rapporto fatto dalla
società nera di marketing che si chiama
i mestieri del marketing si rende
evidente come quasi il 50 per cento
delle richieste di lavoro anno
dentro anche la richiesta di competenze
sales ma soprattutto le imprese cercano
sempre di più competenze elevate alla
loro rete commerciale non solo la
capacità di vendere una cosa di
pianificare e gestire un processo avere
delle skill molto più alte essere più
digitale avere capacità interculturali e
il professore chi si occupa di ricerca
in questo mondo ma sicuramente hanno da
tempo lavorato su questo tema 1999
giugno a causa di un marketing science
barton waits un po fu dello collega
americano bravissimo citava il nostro il
vostro venditore è il primo creatore di
valore per la vostra impresa il punto di
vista è molto chiaro il tema è che fra
queste prospettive
c'è un abisso quello del mio studente è
quello degli scolari allora c'è bisogno
di far ragionare di far riflettere su
questo su questo tema perché le
prospettive sono molto diversi allora
due riflessioni
la prima riflessione è cambierà questo
stereotipo cambierà questa idea di
vedere e semplificata la realtà senza
andarci dentro e fare delle scelte
non considerando questa carriera sì con
una certa certezza gli studi accademici
che abbiamo rintracciato negli ultimi 40
anni ci dice che l'atteggiamento nei
confronti di questo tema non è
assolutamente cambiata gli stereotipi e
fanno fatica a cambiare nella realtà non
sono 40 anni fa dallo studio che sto
facendo con un collega sociologo
emergere con chiarezza che lo stereotipo
era già presente nel medioevo non si
chiamava commerciale si chiamava
commerciante ma allo stereotipo è
assolutamente quello però attenzione che
questo ha una ricaduta economica forte
perché se le imprese cercano quel tipo
di profili i genitori e figli ed altri
non vogliono quella carriera il tempo di
missione al lavoro crea dei costi
notevoli nell'ultimo rapporto
realizzato da facebook edition fondation
stima in 180mila dollari i costi di
formazione di un manager delle vendite
che parte dal basso e arriva la pc quest
esternalità non ce la possiamo
permettere e penso che questi due mondi
devono fortemente parlare penso che
molto c'è da fare pensando che prima di
affidarci ad uno stereotipo dobbiamo
immaginare che quel mondo è cambiato e
cambiato fortemente pensare che quella
figura che noi chiamiamo venditore
chiaramente non è solo venditore a lui
gli diamo una visione sempre di più
strategiche sempre meno operativa
competenze digitali competenze di
internazionale competenze dal lato
marketing ma vogliamo sempre una figura
formata e sempre come stile sales molto
concreta grazie
[Applauso]